right so last time which was quite a
while ago we were talking about
intelligence in general and the way that
you can model intelligence as an
optimization process
this was the hill-climbing algorithm
yeah that was an example that we gave we
were using evolution as an example of an
optimizing algorithm or an optimizing
system anyway and then we were using
that as a way of talking about other
types of intelligence we were talked
about chess AI very briefly that kind of
thing so then the question is what's the
difference between the type of AI that
we have now the type of AI that might
play chess or drive a car or when
jeopardy or whatever versus the ideas
that we have of AI in the future the
kind of science-fiction a is that what
you might call true AI what is it that
really makes the difference is it a
matter just of power or is there
something else and one real
distinguishing factor is generality and
what that means is how broad a set of
domains can the intelligence acting can
it optimize in so if you take a chess ai
it's very intelligent in the domain of
chess and it is absolutely useless in
almost any other domain if you put a
chess AI in a Google self-driving car
not only can it not drive the car it
doesn't have the concept doesn't know
what a car is it doesn't have any of the
necessary architecture cognitive
architecture to drive a car and vice
versa
right the Google car can't play chess
and it can't win at jeopardy whereas we
have a working example of a general
intelligence which is human intelligence
right human brains can do a lot of
different things in a lot of different
domains including brand-new domains the
domains we didn't evolve for
particularly so in fact chess right we
invented chess we invented driving and
then we learned to become good at them
so a general intelligence
is in a sense a different class of thing
because it's a single optimization
system that's able to optimize in a very
broad variety of different domains and
if we could build an artificial general
intelligence that's kind of the holy
grail of AI research that you have a
single program or a single system that's
able to solve any problem that we throw
at it or at least tackle any problem
that we throw at it recently professor
browse what we did the idea of the
Turing test so that's trying to me from
what you're saying is that that's a very
specific domain pretending to be a human
talking yes in a sense it's a very
specific domain the Turing test is
necessary but not sufficient test for
general intelligence you could it
depends how you format your test right
because you could say well if the AI has
to pretend to be a human convincingly
cheering's was during this original test
was only in a brief conversation using
only text but you could say to convince
me you're a human tell me what move I
should make in this chess game to
convince me up you're human tell me how
I would respond in this driving
situation or what's the answer to this
jeopardy question so you can immature in
tests deliberately test a wide variety
of other domains but in general
conversation is one domain yeah you
could formulate a true Turing test in
that way but it would take longer and be
more sort of rigorous one way of
thinking about general intelligence is
domain-specific intelligence but where
the domain is the world or physical
reality and if you can reliably optimize
the world itself that is in a sense what
general intelligence does is that like
humans have been changing the world to
meet their needs
absolutely so when you say changing the
world obviously we've been changing the
world on a very grand scale but
everything that humans do in the real
world is in a sense changing the world
to be better optimized to them
right like if I'm thirsty and there's a
drink over there then picking it up and
putting it to my lips and drinking I'm
changing the world to
my hydration levels which is something
that I value so I'm sort of optimizing
I'm using my intelligence to optimize
the world around me in a very abstract
sense but also quite practically but
putting it on a bigger scale as you say
on a grander scale building it down and
irrigating a field and putting a pipe to
your house and allowing you to have a
tap yeah it's doing the same thing but
on a grander scale right and there's no
hard boundary between those two things
it's the same basic mechanism at work
the idea that you want things to be in
some way different from how they are so
you use your intelligence to come up
with a series of actions or a plan that
you can implement that will make a world
that better satisfies your values and
that's that's what a true AI a general
AI would do as well so you can see the
the metaphor to optimization is still
there right you've got this vast state
space which is all possible states of
the world remember before we were
talking about dimensionality and how
it's kind of a problem if you have too
many dimensions so when we have a
two-dimensional space you take a
particular this is what kills basic
implementations of general AI off the
bat because the world is so very very
complicated it's an exceptionally high
dimensional space with the I'm drinking
a drink example you've got the same
thing again you've got a state of the
world which is a place in this space and
you've got another state of the world
which is the state in which I've just
had a drink and that one of them is
higher in my utility function it's
higher in my ordering my preference
ordering overworld states so I'm going
to try and move I'm going to try and
shift the world from places that are
lower in my preference ordering to
places that are higher and that gives
you a way to express the making of plans
and they're implementing of actions and
intelligent behavior in the real world
in mathematical terms it's not you can't
just implement it because because of
this enormous dimensionality problem all
these dimensions
trying to brute-force infinite
dimensions you're gonna fall over pretty
quickly yeah yeah immediately change the
world right and if that sounds a little
bit threatening it is we'd like to thank
audible.com for sponsoring this
computerphile video and if you like
books go over to audible.com slash
computerphile
there's a chance to try a book for free
now I spoke to rob who was in this
computer file video asked him what book
he would recommend and he says super
intelligence by Nick Bostrom is the one
to check out particularly on this
subject of artificial intelligence we've
got more to come on that subject on
computer file as well so visit
audible.com slash computer file check
out superintelligence and thanks once
again to audible.com for sponsoring this
computer file video so when we have a
two-dimensional space you take a
particular creature there we have this
put this interface chip here this shoe